[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ومرحبا المشاهدين
رئيس الموريتاني السابق محمد ولد عبد
العزيز بشكل وصف بن لاداء الرئيس الحليم
محمد ولد الشيخ الغزواني
النظام الحالي بنظام الرموز وداعيا الى
تغييره سلميه عبر الاستحقاقات الانتخابيه
المقبله
السيد محمد والجبريل رئيس جمهوريه التغيير
والوزير السابق سيد محمد والجبريل اهلا
ومرحبا شكرا جزيلا لك على تربيه هذه
الدعوه
اهلا وسهلا
وكل الترحيب في الجانب المقابل ايضا بضيف
دائما عبر الاقمار الصناعيه السيد محمد
عالي العبادي الاكاديمي والباحث السياسي
سيد علي العبادي اهلا بك ومرحبا شكرا
جزيلا لك ايضا على تلبيه هذه الدوله
في اوضاع جيده وتدهورت هذه الاوضاع بعدي
الى اقصى الحدود كما تردد احوال المواطنين
في كافه المجالات الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
وتراجعت الحريات في البلد هكذا يقول
الرئيس السابق هل هو على صواب ما تعليقكما
على هذه الانتقادات اللاذقيه التي وجهها
للرئيس الحالي محمد ولد الشيخ الغزواني
والي حصيته وهل هي مبرره اطرح عليك السؤال
الاول السيد محمد جبريل رئيس حزب جبهه
رئيس جبهه التغيير والوزير السابق مرحبا
جديد
اهلا وسهلا اولا ااا ودونا نتقدم الشكر
الى قناتكم محترمه والى كل المشاهدين عبر
العالم العربي
ودوا ايضا ان نتوجه بالشكر لجزيلا لساكنه
مدينه الوادي العاصمه الاقتصاديه لبلدنا
على باسمي وبسمي همم
صلاه على نفسي وهمم نيابه عن الرئيس محمد
ولد عبد العزيز على الاستقبال الحار الذي
استقبلوا به الرئيس محمد بن عبد العزيز
وعلى حضوته ايضا همم الضيافه
همم
خلال اللحظات سناتي على هذه النقطه تفضل
لو سمحت ومرحبا بك من جديد
الصوت غير مسموح شكرا لو قلت ان قلت ان
الانتقادات التي قدم الرئيس التي اعتقدت
مبرره وان الحاله التي يعيشها الاقتصاد
الموريتاني والتي يعيشها الشعب الموريتاني
اليوم هي حاله همم خطيره جدا في القوه
الشرائيه للمواط الموريتاني انهارت واصبحت
الاسر الموريتانيه الضعيفه همم تعيش وحاله
من
التردد الاقتصادي ما جاء على المواطنين
اليوم يعيشون حاله اقتصاديه صعبه
والمستشفيات اصبحت اليوم
في في معظم المدن على القيام بمهامها ولم
يكن هنالك جديد على كل حال لان الجميع
يعني ان هذه الحكومه لم تستدعي انجاز اي
شيء ما اريد ان اقوله هو ايضا ان الحريه
فقط بالامس
في قبل امس استقبال الجماهير في انوال ابو
تم السجن وتوقيف المئات من المواطنين
الاحرار فقط لانهم ارادوا تحيه الرئيس
محمد ولد عبد العزيز في كل المفوضيات
الشرطه في نوادي امتلات ولم يعد هنالك
مكان لاستقبال وتوقيف مواطن الجدد هذه
الحاله غير مباركه ليس هنالك ما يبرر كل
هذه
التراجع هذا التراجع الذي حدث في حريه
التعبير
وحريه الصحابه انتم تعلمون ايضا ان ان
الصحابه في موريتانيا كانت تمتلك احزاب
كانت تمتلك قنوات حره اي قنوات كانت
مفتوحه على الاحزاب والجهات معارضه لم تكن
هناك قنوات حره وان كانت هناك بينما هي
فقط
لتكرر ما تقوم به الاجهزه الرسميه ووسائل
الاعلاميه اذا همم ضيفي الى ذلك ان الشباب
في جميع مناطق موريتانيا
نحن همم في
عمل الحزب حزب الرباط الوطني بتقديم طلب
الى الجهات الرسميه
لاستقبال الرئيس لم تم اولا مماطه هنا
وبعد الطويل المماطلات تم ترخيص همم قاعه
صغيره جدا وكاد ان تكون هنالك كارثه ولم
تكن هناك يعني من الله سبحانه وتعالى لان
القاعده التي تم ترخيصها لا يمكن ان ان
تستقبل الا ثلاثه الاف شخص وكان عدد
الوافدين الاكثر من ثلاث الاف
وقناه كسر تعرض لكارثه لو لم يكون هناك
حاله انضباط من طرف المواطنين ست همم
سيكون لسان حال ضيف الجانب المقابل لانه
انقطع الاتصال به هل ربطنا الاتصال مع
ضيفي من جديد سيد محمد علي
العبادي همم رئيسه النشره ميناء اسمع اكشن
طيب جدا كنتم كنتم ساكن بعض الشيء كنت
ساكون لسان حالك وسارد على ضيفي همم سيد
محمد الجبريل رئيس جبهه التغيير والوزير
السابق نقطه بنقطه ولكن بان الاتصال قطعه
همم الخص لك باختصار شديد ما قاله اولا
تحدث عن نقطه الاستقبال الحار ل- الرئيس
السابق عليها خلال لحظات فقط تترك هذه
النقطه جانبا حين نسال عن القدره على
التعبير يقول لك حاله الاقتصاد خطيره
الاسره تعيش حاله من التردد الاقتصادي
المنشات الصحيه تردد المنشات الصحيه التي
بناها ورعاها الرئيس السابق الحكومه
الحاليه لم تقوم باي شيء الحريه تراجع تم
سجن وتوقيف مئات المواطنين الذين جاءوا
الى ان اديب فقط رغبه منهم في تحيه همم
الرئيس ولا مبرره يقول لك لهذه الترجعات
على مستوى الهمم على مختلف المستويات لذلك
وفقه فعلا همم ما ذهب اليه الرئيس السابق
مبرر من تصريحات تفضل سيد محمد علي
العبادي الاكاديمي البحث السياسي وتاخذ
نفس الوقت لو سمحت
اولا اولا اشكركم اشكركم قناه على هذه
الاستضافه رغم انني لم اسمع ما قال ضيفكم
همم كل ما سمعته وكلام والكلام لسان عندما
يقول كلام على عوامه يمكن ان يقول كل شيء
همم لا يمكن ان يكذب الوزير والذي هو عارف
بحقائق همم موجوده على الارض انه في
السابق كانت هناك ازمه سياسيه كبيره كانت
هناك معارضه تشكك في شرعيه الرئيس السابق
وظلت تلك همم ظل ذلك التوتر هو الطابع
العام للحياه السياسيه
تم توقيف الكثير من المدونين الى غير ذلك
اذا
نحن في مجال الحريه اعتقد بانه الان هناك
همم
نوع من الهدوء السياسي الطبقه السياسيه
الان كلها تتحاور فيما بينها وتتفق على
امورها حتى ان هذه الانتخابات هي اول
انتخابات تتفق الطبقه السياسيه على
تنظيمها وتتفق على لجنتها المستقله في
السابق كانت هناك دائما اطراف سياسيه
تعارض النظام وظلت مقصيه وضله تتعرض
للانتقاد وتتعرضوا للتشويه اذا تم كذلك
تغيير الدستور بدون ان يكون هناك اجماع تم
كذلك القضاء على مجلس الشيوخ بدون ان يكون
هناك اجماع اذا مادلت هناك قرارات
انفراديه لا تموت بصله الى الحريه ولا تمت
بسله الى الى الى الى الى التفريق او
استقلال المؤسسات الديمقراطيه لان اعتقد
بان الاعتداء على المؤسسات الديمقراطيه
والقضاء عليها واستغ وفود الدوله من اجل
ان تكون هذه المؤسسات في خبر كان ويتم
تسويه نهائيا حتى لا ت همم لا تعود مره
اخرى اذا كذلك محاربه المعارضه حتى انها
تم القضاء عليها نهائيا وزعماء المعارضه
الان التاريخيين اصبحوا في خبر كان نتيجه
لتجفيف المنابع نتيجه للانتقادات نتيجه
للهجاء الى غير ذلك اذا نعتقد بان هذه
الامور كانت واضحه وكنا نشاهدها وكنا
نراقبها
المشهد الوطني اذا تم همم الحياه السياسيه
حتى الان نحن الان في احزاب سياسيه تتلاقى
ما فيها حزب الرباط الذي همم يحتضن الرئيس
السابق محمد بن عبد العزيز اذا اعتقد بان
هذا الحوار وهذا التشاور وهذا التلاقي ما
بين الاحزاب السياسيه وهذه الاجنده التي
عليها اضغط السياسيه لا تمكن لا يمكن ان
نصنفها في اطار همم
في اطار همم القضاء على الحريات والتقدير
الحريات الان في مجال حقوقا ايضا قبل فتره
قصيره كان هناك رئيس المجلس الاعلى لحقوق
الانسان وقد عبر عن رضا همم لاتحاد
الاوروبي وقد عبر وقد عبر عن الرضا لحاله
حقوق الانسان
الحلقه
الوزير السابق يقول لك ذاكره الناس ليس
ضعيفه وحصله الرئيس السابق سيئه وسلبيا
للغايه ما انك تحدثت عن هذا الاستقبال
للحار سيد محمد ولد جبريل كثير هنا تحدث
عن عشرات الاشخاص فقط الذين هبوا
ربما
البعض جاء
ليرى ما يحدث فقط ااا ليس دعما حتى لي
الرئيس
السابق هنا اود ان اسالك ما مدى قدره
الرئيس السابق في حشد الناس بالنظر ل اا
وتعبيئتهم بالنظر لي الحشود التي قدرها
البعض بالعشرات فقط التي تافهه حولها ما
مدى قدرته على التعبئه السياسيه وترد ايضا
على مذهب اليه في سيدنا محمد علي العبادي
تفضل
شكرا اييه الصور التي وال
نقل المباشر الحي الذي وصل جميع في
موريتانيا وخارج موريتانيا من استقبال
المواطنين في نوادي بولى الرئيس محمد عبد
العزيز اعتقد انها تغندوا كل الدعايات
المغرضه التي الهدف منها هو همم تصوير هذه
الاستقبال على انه ليس استقبال جماهيري
ولكن الرئيس محمد بن عبد العزيز وصل الى
العاصمه الاقتصاديه نوادي بو الساعه
الواحده زوالا واضل في المضايقات
كافه وسائل الامن في مدينه الموالي به وتم
همم وسائل اخرى
للحي الاولى التي دون وصول
المواطنين الذين يريدون استقبال الرئيس
وراهم كل ذلك
الالاف من المواطنين نجحوا في سد الخطه
السياسيه التي قام بها قامت بها السلطات
وقبل ذلك بيوم الس ابداعات جميع موظفين
الى العمل في ايام همم نهايه الاسبوع وهذا
خارج عن القانون وايضا تم تعبئه كل
الصحافه وتم تكميم الافواه حتى الصحابه
الرسميه والصحابه الحره لم تقوم بنقل ما
جرى من وادي ولكن كانت هناك امواج بشريه
السياسيه
اينما حل اينما حل يلتحم حوله الشعب
الموريتاني لان الرئيس محمد عبد العزيز
خدم الشعب الموريتاني
والانجازات التي يستفاد من الشعب
الموريتاني
لا يحتاج الى العوده
لانه كل ما قاله انا بالنسبه لي ما يخص
الدستور الشعب موريتاني هو ما صوت
المجلس الشيوخ وهذا وهذه اراده الشعب
والدستور موريتانيا يقول ان السلطه بهذه
الشعب الشعب هو الفيصل والرئيس محمد بن
عبد العزيز هو من اوصل للرئيس الحالي
للسلطه وقال بالامس بان ذلك كان خطا وان
الشعب لما صوت بطلب منه الرئيس
الرئيس محمد عبد العزيز تثبت بجلاء ان
التغيير اصبح مساله الوقت وانا الانتخابات
التي تتكلم معها ضيفكم هي انتخابات لديها
احتمالين ضعنا فقط اضيف ان هذه الانتخابات
التي يتكلم عنها هي انتخابات لا يمكن
الوصفه بتوافقيه لانهم هم شكلوا ما يسمى
بمؤامره ضد الشعب معناه المعارضه القديمه
والموالات يعني شكله مؤامره
وبقيه الرئيس محمد بن عبد العزيز الى جانب
الشعب وهم يسيرون البلد اهم
جبريل حتى لا يكون خطاب احادي سواء
بالنسبه للسيد علي العبادي همم لم يكونوا
بالعشرات سيد علي العبادي تعقب على مذهب
اليه بالكان وبالمئات هب بدون ترتيبات
مسبقه يقول انصار الرئيس السابق لقاءه في
هذا المهرجان همم الشعب هنا اطرح عليه نفس
السؤال ما كنت تتفق مع ضيفي ما مدى قدره
الرئيس السابق على تعبئه الشارع همم لحيه
لاغراض انتخابيه خاصه مع دعوتنا تغيير
النظام القائم عبر استحقاقات الانتخابيه
المقبله سيد علي العبادي تفضل
اولا اعتقد همم
بان الدعايه السياسيه يمكن ان يقول فيها
الانسان كل ما يحلو له
وخاصه اذا كان همم رئيس
سابق همم يحلم بالعوده الى الى الرئاسه
ويحلم همم
بانجازات ربما لم يجد من بين انصاره الذي
كان الذين كان همم
يعول عليهم اي احد يمكن ان يعقد معه
ونستغربت في تدمير سابقه همم قول الرئيس
السابق بان الدوله همم
بان النفوذ الدوله يمكن ان يعاند وان
الدوله لا يمكن ان يكون بيديها كل شيء
والرئي السابق هو الذي كان يستخدم نفوذ
الدوله استخدم نفوذ الدوله انا ذاك عندما
اجبر المواطنين على التصويت لمن يحل له
التصويت لهم استغل هذه التصويت على
الدستور الذي كانت تعارضه المعارضه بجميع
اوجهها
قال لي الدوله بجميع النواحي استغلتها
بكثير من القضايا التي تملك
منعتقد بان هذه الامور لا يمكن يعود الى
السلطه
بما يتعلق بمهرجان
الرئيس السابق قد تم بحشد كبير انا اعتقد
بان مهرجان حسب ما لدي من معلومات كان
مهرجان صغيرا كان في همم في في مكان طيب
لا يمكن ان يعول عليه همم يمكن ان يعول
عليه حقيقه في عوده الرئيس السابق ولافي
دغدغه العواطف التي ربما يحلو له همم
هل هو قادر على ذلك
الشارع همم
انا اعتقد ان رئيس الان ان رئيس الان تم
توجيه ملفه لمحكمه الفساد
ولم يبرئ نفسه حتى الان لا يمكن ان يعبي
شارعا لديه من الطموح ولديه من الرغبات
ماء ماء ماء ماء ماء ماء ماء ماء ما يحل
به مشكلاته اعتقد بان الرئيس السابق لو
كان بامكانه حل مشكلات الشعب الموريتاني
لا قضيه على تلك المشكلات ولا استطاع ان
يترشح لماموريه ذلك تلك الماموريه التي
رفضها الشعب الموريتاني ورفضته المعارضه
لهذا الرئيس
الحالي انا اعتقد بان الرئيس الحالي جاءت
به الانتقابات وكذلك عندما استلم السلطان
بدا في ترميم بما كان فاسدا في زمن الرئيس
كل
سيد علي العبادي لو سمحت استسمحك فقط
تعودي ليس تولد جميل هل يحلم الرئيس
السابق بالعوده تعقب بطبيعه الحاله مذهله
اليه في ضيفي هل يحلم بالعوده الى الرئاسه
ام انه صراحه يحاول من خلال تكثيف تحركات
سياسيه في الخارج اولا ثم في الداخل ثانيا
اعطاء طابع سياسي لقضيته تلك المتعلقه
بالفساد كما ينتقده معارضوه
الرئيس السابق محمد ولد عبد العزيز همم في
قضيه همم وصول للرئيس الحالي الى السلطه
الدعاء مناصره الى التصويت الى الرئيس
الحالي وانتخبه ولو لم يقوم بتلك الدعوه
لما كان الرئيس الحالي رئيسا هذا همم
شفت كان فقدت من اجل رجوع الى ما تدخل به
ضيوفكم في من مقالطاتهم يخص الماضي همم
الرئيس محمد بن عبد العزيز طالب همم
استقباله جمهور في وادي وكان هناك قصر
لمؤتمرات وكان
همم العادي ان تتجاوب السلطه اجابا ترخيص
هذا القصر
ولكن السلطه
في مناسبتين على الاقل ولكن انا ما سالتك
يعني هل يحاول الرئيس او يرغب في اطفاء
سياسي نعم على محاكمته للتهرب من
مسؤولياته بمعنى ان يقال في لحظه ماء انه
يتم اجتهاده همم لانه يمارس المعارضه هذا
سؤالي لو سمحت
الرئيس محمد بن عبد العزيز
نهايته اموريه الثانيه وهو يقول انه سيبقى
في ساحه السياسيه ولم يتغير اي شيء الذي
تغير هو النهج الذي سار عليها هذا النظام
من فساد ومن تدمير لكل مؤسسات الدوله
وليكن اقتصاد الوطني ولما لاحظ ذلك من
نزوله الاولى عارض هذا النظام الشده ولما
عارض النظام قام النظام بالتوفيق هذا
الملف ومن ذلك الوقت نحن في تصفيه حسابات
السياسيه لبعض يقولوا هذا الكلام الذي
تسمعونه ولكن لا يوجد هناك ملف هذا هذه
الحكومه هي افسد الحكومه عرفت عرفت
موريتانيا لان المؤشرات جميع المؤشرات
بماذا هي حوري التعبير موريتانيا وصلت الى
46 تونس اه اليوم مؤشر الحريه موريتانيا
هو 97 ايه جميع الارقام في التضخم
والاسعار
وهناك فوضع في الامن المواطنين يقتلون في
جميع حدود موريتانيا هناك عالم في جميع
القطاعات هل الرئيس التفت حوله جماعه من
المفسدين
والتهمت مع المعارضه الميزانيه التي تضعفت
مرتين لان ما كان يوجز بنصف هذه الميزانيه
اليوم لا يمكنه لم يجزي اي شيء اذن هم
بدلوا اموال الدوله والانه يحاولون ان
يقدموا الرئيس محمد عبد العزيز على انهو
متابعين هذه
ولا يقبل ذلك فقط
فقط فقط اسمح لي فقط فقط ساعطيك الوقت تمت
حاله ملف الرئيس الموريتاني سابق الى
محكمه جرائم الفساد لم يبقى الا ان تحدد
المحكمه موعدا للمحاكمه ضيف يقول تلفيق
لهذا همم ملف وتصفيه حسابات سياسيه ضيف
الى ذلك اتهامات فساد كبيره وخطيره همم
النظام الحالي ويقول لك لديه الارقام
والمؤشرات تدل كلها على ذلك اختم معك سيد
علي العبادي لو سمحت انا اعتقد انا اعتقد
اننا اذا اذا اذا اذا اذا رجعنا ابتعدنا
عن الدعايات السياسيه وانا لست سياسيا
لامارس الدعايه السياسيه اذا ابتعدنا عن
ذلك فاننا يعتقد بان الرئيس السابق كان
ملف اجمع عليه البرلمان هذه البرلمان
الذين لقب في فتراته وكذلك الاطراف
السياسيه في المعارضه لان اعتقد بان هذا
الملف تم انطلاقه من مؤسسه دستوريه
التشريعيه والتي قامت بالتحقيق فيه وتمت
حالته وتمت دراسته الى ان تم تحجيمه بما
هو عليه الان لنعتقد انه كان من الاجداد
انا اعتقد ان العداله يجب ان تاخذها ويجب
ان يترك المجال الحقيقيه
وان نبتعد عن محاكمه الرئيس الذي يحاول
الرئيس السابق ان يستغل له الان اشكركم
جزيل الشكر على تلبيه هذه الدعوه سيد محمد
جبريل رئيس جبهه التغيير والوزير السابق
كل شكرا جزيلا لك من واكشوط محمد علي
العبادي لكديم البحث السياسي شكرا جزيلا
لك ايضا كنتم معنا في فقره وجهها لوجه
ملتقى